[Music]
YouTube is launching its first ever
comedy week it's sort of an online
comedy festival and it began yesterday
now like everybody I love watching
videos on YouTube and lately I've been
making my own video responses and
posting them in the comments section
that's true it's kind of addictive and I
thought it'd be fun to do a YouTube
video response right now in the studio
on the show sound good to you but I'm
gonna respond right now this is a real
video called householdhacker this is
absolutely real and I watched it and I
was fascinated by it's called
householdhacker quick and simple life
hacks part 8 check it out this is quick
and simple life hacks where we solve
your everyday problems with a little
MacGyver inspired ingenuity one your ice
cream to last longer without getting
ruined wrap the box and tinfoil and they
will keep out the frost and preserve
your delicious treat an ice tray leaking
a bit stay cool and grab an empty egg
carton fill it up for an excellent
replacement having trouble cracking open
that glass jar going to your sink and
grab a rubber cleaning gloves that
little bit of extra grip will have you
enjoying those pickles in no time and
finally you want to light a candle but
that lighter won't reach grab a dried
stick of spaghetti and light it instead
it's gonna burn nice and slow and let
you get to those hard-to-reach places as
always please share your favorite life
hacks in the comments below and we'll
see you next time
alright well it's time for my video
response hi Conan O'Brien here I just
watched householdhacker life hacks part
8 and I'll have my own thoughts here's
another tip if you've got ice cream in a
container and you don't want it to get
freezer burn how about eating the rest
of the ice cream
if you have eggs but no egg carton use
an ice tray the eggs should fit in the
ice tray if they don't just force them
if you want to eat spaghetti but all
your spaghetti has been burned up
because you were trying to relight a
candle you should have thrown away a
long time ago
eat the candle and finally if you're
having some trouble opening jars it's
probably because you have no nutrition
in your body because all your eggs are
in the freezer all your spaghetti is
burned up and you've been eating nothing
but candles for six weeks so go to the
hospital and forget the rubber glove
you've got much bigger problems well
this is partner Brian please subscribe
to my channel you can check out some of
my other video responses on my youtube
channel at youtube.com slash team
[Applause]